so how did you meet Ming Geller in the
first place the first time I was aware
of Anthony was actually through my
mother my mom was a teacher originally
and then decided to take up a follow her
passion for theater and she set up a
theater company and one of her first
plays was a little like drowning which
was one of Anthony's first plays and she
wrote to Antony and asked for some
advice and him in his typical embracive
and passionate way invited her over for
lunch and talked her through the entire
play
and so I remembered then his name and I
remember seeing the play and I was a
familiar familiar with him and his work
and then
I'm embarrassed to say it to say this he
so he came to I was working with his
wife doing this very odd little British
film with it with a Chinese director and
his wife was producing it and he offered
me the part of Dickie Greenleaf in the
talented mr. Ripley and he'd just won
he just went nine Oscars for The English
Patient and I turned the part I don't
know why I think I was I think I I don't
know what I was thinking I I think if
I'm honest I was you know I was like
twenty five or six and I sort of thought
it was a I don't know I thought it was a
part that played too much on just good
looks and it wasn't you know it wasn't a
lot to it and he thank goodness he came
and saw me and sort of taught me through
the possibilities in this role and and
we embarked on what ended up being a
wonderful creative collaboration we did
Ripley we did cold mountain then we did
his his final film before he passed away
braking and injury I read somewhere that
around the time of this movie Minghella
said about you something like your
greatest obstacle as an actor was your
looks by which he meant I think that
that he worried that you know that you
could be typecast only as a leading man
and then
and that people would not know what a
very good actor you are besides being a
very good-looking one it's a nice
problem to have a lot but has it worked
out that way in your career do you think
do you think that that you have had have
you had to struggle to get out from
underneath that or is it it's a it's a
very uncomfortable and odd
it's a conversation to have in a way
because by by discussing it is like
confirming that I think I'm this
incredibly good-looking you know I mean
although I have to say looking at that
which I can at the age of 43 I was very
pretty but you know like anyone you wake
up and you you you you love your face
you hate your face you you know you your
face is your face and you I mean I would
also add that you know the thing the
thing that looks in in an acting career
is that they you know there are um
they're unconventionally unconventional
looking actors who have fantastic
careers because their unconventional
looking so it's not always a given that
people think you're good-looking
therefore you're going to have this
wonderful career or not get offered I
think in the end you'll found out and
it's it's there for what you choose to
do and and and and and what you deliver
and sure there was it there was a time
went well I think turning turning down
that part initially was was was a
perfect example of this there was a time
early on when I thought oh I could I
should only do character roles I should
only do really odd ugly people so that
you know everyone takes me seriously and
then of course you realize that you're
kind of
you know you're cutting your own
Achilles heel then it's like it's like
just get on with it and see what comes
your way but equally choose wisely and
carefully
I think probably my favorite of your
recent movies is Dom Hemingway and old I
wish I wish we could have a clip of that
I'm not surprised you down the opening
modeling baby
no the the well it's it's hard to
explain it except that you play this
this kind of second-rate safecracker who
gets out of jail and but part of what
makes it so wonderful is you seem to be
taking terrific pleasure and you look
really seedy in this movie you seem
really to be enjoying that well it was
in true what was lovely was thinking
okay you know you've got to create the
face of a man who spent 16 years in
prison who's been drunk for possibly 25
years of his life
and bears the scars of all sorts of you
know injuries and mistakes and problems
and so sitting with a very talented
makeup artist and just looking at how
you put all of that on in into the face
and without wearing prosthetics it's fun
because then you feel like you've got
the mask of the character and once
you've got that mask you can you
disappear into him or her the other
great thing about this movie is is that
he has these monologues that yeah and
they're like they're like the monologues
in a play yeah more than him they
reminded me like that and I think that's
something that really appealed to me you
know he loved the sound of his own voice
and he reminded me of a sort of full
staff Ian kind of a drunk who would and
was also even though he was an
uneducated man and not a man he probably
read very much he he had a wonderful way
with words and Richard Shepherd who
wrote it and directed it really embraced
that that type of
drunk and I thought you know put some
beautiful words together there was a lot
of fun to learn and a lot of fun to play
it to has a wonderful accent well that's
my eye that's where that really that's
your act one thing I said to Richard was
because at the time I read it he he kind
of got his geography of London wrong in
fact yeah we had been to London but he'd
said this while it sort of looking at a
map and didn't real anyway and I kept
saying no if this guy's from here he
can't go there and he would know but you
know so he went back and I took him to
the part of London I grew up southeast
London and I grew up in an area called
Lewis shim but we decided to put Dom in
an area called Wallach he so he gave him
a bullet Jack's and there were guys I
went to school with who I'm sure became
chaps like Dom Hemingway because well
they was pretty terrifying when I knew
them as a as a boy so when you're a boy
going to school with these terrifying
guys do you already know that you're
gonna be an actor when did that that's
why I was terrified of them I was this
pretty blond kid called Jude who wanted
to be an actor
[Laughter]
full of enthusiasm about the theatre and
films and I usually got thumped by them
yeah I knew I knew pretty but very young
age that it was something I wanted to
follow I had parents who were teachers
and who were great enthusiastic for
theater and film and I grew up being
taken to the theater a lot and going to
the cinema a lot and it was just a
passion I was a real sponge for it I
loved it and then at the first
opportunity as a kid in school putting
on plays it just felt like a
a dialogue a place where I was
comfortable I remember putting on plays
as a class with the teacher obviously
directing and just thinking it didn't
feel like class this felt like play and
it felt easy it felt comfortable I felt
at home and I guess as soon as I made
the connection that that could also be a
job that you would do
it seemed like um an obvious direction
to go in
and then you know the passion takes over
when when you also realize there's a
snot serious element that an element of
you can you can actually have a voice
you can you can bring bring a voice to
things that you care about people that
you care about subject matters that you
care about so unlike a lot of British
actors of your generation you you didn't
go to the Royal Academy you didn't go I
mean you started quite young actually
learning on the job right yeah yeah I
was a member of the National Youth Music
Theatre from the age of 13 which was a
company and we were a comfort that was a
company that still operates and we would
meet during the holidays and improvise
and put on theatre that we would then
take to festivals around the country and
I got off at a job on TV and I left
school new parents are okay with that
they were I was teachers it was very
interesting I think they knew that it
was something I took very seriously and
I think we agreed that if it all went
wrong I agree that I would go to my
education and and that was it I didn't I
didn't really stop I did an awful lot of
theater first I mean film didn't seem
like a reality but you know I would go
and see movies all the time but being a
film actor or being in a having a film
career just didn't seem realistic in
Lewisham it felt like a distant
it felt like a you know something that
happened a lot well it did happen a long
long way away but it just didn't seem
conceivable to get into that world
whereas theater you know you drove pot
you drive past theaters all the time as
you do here in New York and in London
there they are so the even the idea of
going and asking for a job seemed
impossible and it it felt also that I
was following look not that I did it
necessarily consciously but following in
the footsteps of a British tradition of
cutting my teeth on the stage and I'm
really grateful for that I feel that it
enabled me to become much more aware of
the
the mechanics of being an actor and the
demands of being an actor and also their
respect for the process in the craft of
being an actor were there people that
you you took as models with yet were
there actors that you particularly
admired and certainly I mean as a child
I was a huge fan of
Paul Newman and Steve McQueen I mean I'm
gonna say all the obvious ones I mean
the greats and and then and then the
generation of British actors ahead of me
people like Gary Oldman Tim Roth Daniel
day-lewis were huge heroes Sean Penn
I think I think the thing I loved about
them in particular was the variety of
roles they were playing that none of
them seemed to you know I remember in
one year seeing my beautiful laundrette
and then run with a view and I just
couldn't believe it was the same actor
who had done both and and having that in
mind the opportunity of keeping yourself
guessing and keeping your audience
guessing as to what you would do next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]